-Obviously, John Mulaney,
that was a given...
But "The Sack Lunch Bunch,
where did you come up with that?
-"The Sack Lunch Bunch"?
I wanted, like, a name
of, like, a groovy old,
like, name, like, in the '70s.
You know, there would be shows
that were like, you know,
The Scrapyard Gang and stuff
And I wanted to call it
"The Latchkey Kids" 'cause -
Do you remember that term?
-Yes.
-I was, like,
a latchkey kid, I guess,
'cause my parents had jobs
so we'd come home, you know?
And we'd watch TV,
and we'd enjoy it.
And on the news,
they'd be like,
"Latchkey kids.
It's a terrible thing."
And we'd be like,
"No, it's not."
And, then,
Sack Lunch Bunch, you know -
Two words of it rhyme.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Not a lot of science to it.
-You -- There are so many
wonderful songs in this.
-Yes. Wonderful composer,
Eli Bolin.
-Eli Bolin. Yeah.
-Who we worked with
on "Documentary Now!"
-"Documentary Now!"
He's fantastic.
We've written songs
together before.
-You wrote an
Emmy Award-winning song.
-We won an Emmy. We wrote a song
with Justin Timberlake.
And we won an Emmy.
-Yeah. Now, question.
-Yes.
-Okay.
We want to -- Okay.
So, this song was a monologu
song for Justin Timberlake
On the ballot of the Emmys
it said
"Justin Timberlake Song."
-Yeah.
-Then below it was the muc
more popular "Mother Lover
by The Lonely Island...
with Justin Timberlake
and Andy Samberg.
-Yeah.
-But ours was called
"The Justin Timberlake Song.
And we won.
-Yeah.
-I've always wondered,
do you think people though
that that was
The Lonely Island song?
-Yeah.
-I think it's, like,
those weird --
Like, when they have, like
Palm Beach, Florida,
and they show you the ballots,
and you're like,
"Oh, that was
way too confusing."
-Yeah, it was like,
"Justin Timberlake Song?
'Mother Lover'?"
And you're like, "I like tha
one with Justin Timberlake."
-This has so many --
"Grandmother's Boyfriend"
is a fantastic song.
-Oh. "Grandma's Boyfriend Paul."
Thank you.
-Yeah.
"Grandma's Boyfriend Paul.
There's a song called "Noodles
and a Little Bit of Butter."
-"Plain Plate of Noodles."
Yeah. Yeah.
-"Do Flowers Exist at Night.
-"Do Flowers Exist at Night?
I wrote on the subway,
the lyrics.
I have no musical ability.
And it was based on --
I mean, it was --
The lyrics are exactly the
process I went through as a kid.
I couldn't picture
a flower at night.
And if I'm to be honest
with you, I can't now.
-Yeah.
-Can you picture one at night?
-No, I guess not.
-Yeah.
-So I would lay in bed.
And the lyrics are --
"Do flowers exist at night
Do flowers exist at night?
I keep meaning to check,
but I always forget.
To see if flowers exist
at night."
and I remember laying in bed
once when I was like 9,
and I was like,
"I forgot to look again!"
Because we had a couple tulips
in front of our house.
-Yeah.
-I was gonna go see
what they were doing.
-Do the kids ever --
I mean, do they behave on set?
-No. But -- They did.
Like, people -- My friend,
who's a pediatrician and a vet
he says, "Never work
with children and animals.
Thanks.
And, like,
we can cut that out, right
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, my friend --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Kitty McPooch.
-Dr. Kitty McPooch.
-Doctor. Yeah, yeah, thank you
-Dr. McPooch.
-Yeah. He's, uh...
He treats kids and animals
That's why his name from
birth was Kitty McPooch.
-When a guy like that says
don't work with
kids and animals...
-Yeah, but I don't
listen to him, so...
15 kids are great.
They really psych each other up.
They were very supportive
of each other.
They, like -- You know,
some kids might have
a bigger part in one scene
than the other,
and they'd all be like,
"You were great," you know
And in many ways like more -
a little more mature than, like,
people we worked with
at "Saturday Night Live."
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-That sounds a lot nicer tha
our -- And we liked each other
But you still --
-Oh, yeah.
But it would be like, "Oh,
that was yours? Yeah, okay."
But there were 15 of them, and
they would get really riled up
You know when they do
the clap board
and they go, "Apple mark!"
They would yell, like,
"Baker Mark, Charlie mark.
And this one girl every time
would go, "Toilet mark."
And I know it's not funny,
but if you heard it 900 times,
you'd start laughing a lot
And, so Rhys, Thomas,
our wonderful director,
who's like -- who's worked
with every host of "SNL."
-Yes.
-He's worked with everyone
He's been under pressure
many times.
One day, they were just
so, like, out of their minds
And Rhys ran up to them. The
were just all talking at once.
And he went, "Do you behav
in school like this?!"
And one girl went,
"We don't go to school!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-You have, like, I mentioned
some great guys.
Richard Kind, who's one of our
favorite people in the world
There was someone else
you wanted to get.
And this would be who kids today
would want to see the most
-This is what I thought would be
a real crowd-pleaser,
was I wanted former presidential
candidate Michael Dukakis
to be in it.
When I was 6, he was, like
one of the two most famous
people in the world.
But I wanted him
to come on and go,
"John, I think I got one
of your letters by mistake."
And then I'd go, "Hey, everyone,
it's Michael Dukakis!"
And the kids would cheer
for 30 seconds straight.
And I -- He's teaching
at the moment, I guess.
And he said,
"Can I see a script?"
And I wasn't done with it,
so I was like,
"You don't get a script."
You know? [ Laughs ]
Because I was always delaying.
So we didn't get Dukakis
this time around.
-Yeah.
-Kids, I think,
will still enjoy it.
-I think so.
-Yeah.
-Never have we forgot
about a dude more.
-Than Michael Dukakis?
-I mean, like, a lot --
Well, not half but cl--
Almost half of America
wanted him to be
the president
of the United States.
-Yeah.
-And then he lost.
And they were like,
"Get the hell out of here.
-And then yet when I think
about him, I think about him
driving that tank.
-Yeah, he rode a tank
with a helmet on.
-Yeah.
-And that I guess --
-And then somehow that was bad
-Yeah.
-Because the other guys
used it against him.
-Yeah, they were like, "Look
at this idiot." You know?
You can make anyone look bad i
you go, "Look at this idiot,
and then show a clip --
a clip of them.
-Yeah, I mean, like --
I mean, right now, just --
I don't want you
to take this the wrong way
but if you were to run
for president right now,
there's so many things
in this "Sack Lunch Bunch"
that would just sink you
right away.
-Or just take
the pediatrician/vet joke...
and do it in slow motion.
Go, "Look at this idiot."
It'll be me like,
"My friend's a pediatrician...
And you'd win.
-I'd still vote for you.
John Mulaney!
-Thank you.